اليمين والمتطرف في حكومه البنيه المقبله
صداع يؤرق من في الداخل والخارجي بل واقرب
حلفاء اسرائيل
تاريخ بعض الوزراء المحتمله يسير مخاوفه
ويستوجب اتخذه اجراءات لرضع تصرفاتها حتى
قبل ان ترنر
المحتمله لحكومه تضم وزراء لشكلتي اطامار
بن خفير طلب السفير الامريكي السابق لدى
اسرائيل
مع حكومه ستكون الاكثر التطرفا منذ تاسيس
اسرائيل قالت دبلوماسيان في مقال مشترك
نشرته واشنطن بوست ان الظروف مهيئه
للاشتعال عند تولي حكومه السلطه ورجعها
انه في ظل حكومه متحالفه مع حساب يهوديه
متطرفه زياده النشاط للسطاني ومصادره
الاراضي صينيه وارتفاع وتيره العنف
الاسرائيلي تشاهد فلسطينيين توقع ايضا ان
تحاول اسرائيل تغيير الوضع الحالي للقدس
المحتله والمسجد الاقصى تضمن المقال
الاقرب الى رساله مفتوحه للرئيس جوبايدن
دعوه الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه الى تحذير
اسرائيل من اتخاذ اي خطوه لضم الضفه
الغربيه او تغيير وضع الحرم القدسي او
اطفاء الشرعيه على البؤر الاستيطانيه
الى الحكومه عبر تحالفاته المثيره للجدل
مع احبابي اقسى اليمين لم تتوقف الادانه
والانتقاداته للاسوء المرتقب من سلطه
الاحتلال اتفاق نتنياهما حزب القوه
اليهوديه بقيادته
لتولي حقيبه وزاره الامن الداخلي قد تكون
له نتائج وخيمه لا تختصر بنفير سياسي
متطرف معروف بالتصريح المعاديه للعربي وفي
سجله ادانه بتهمه العنصريه
ملامح الحكومه المنتظره كلها اخطار محدقه
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه ومستقبل المفاوضات وحل
الدولتين يا سلام مر الى سلام شبه مستحيل
قد تشهده القضيه الفلسطينيه في ظل حكومه
اسرائيليه هي الاكثر التطرفا منذ تاسيس
الكيان المحتل